حذر نعمان كورتل الموش نائب رئيس الوزراء
التركي الامريكيين من ان سيطره عناصر غير
عربيه على مدينه الرقه السوريه لن يجلب
السلام اليها ياتي هذا بعد اعلان ما تسمى
بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه التي تقودها
الوحدات الكرديه بدء عمليه للسيطره على
الرقه من تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ونناقش فيما
وراءه ما حقيقه الموقف الامريكي من تفرد
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه باعلان البدء في
عمليه للسيطره على
الرقه وما هي خيارات تركيا وقوى المعارضه
السوريه المتحالفه معها لمواجهه تمدد
وحدات الحمايه الكرديه الى
الرقه
لم يخفي الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
وغيره من مسؤولي حكومته رغبتهم في مشاركه
قواتهم في عمليه استعاده الرقه من تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه فهل يعني بدء ما تسمى
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه عمليه للسيطره على
الرقه باسناد امريكي تجاهلا من واشنطن
لرغبه انقره شركتها في حلف النيتو الامر
كان مثار بحث بين رئيسي اركان قوات
البلدين في اجتماع عقد في انقره اكتفى
بيان الصادر عن هذا الاجتماع بالاشاره الى
ان الطرفين ناقش طرقا قتاليه مشتركه ضد
تنظيم الدوله في سوريا والعراق خلال
الايام المقبله فهل جرت تهدئه الهواجس
التركيه تقرير زياد
بركات الى الراي العام تعلن قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه وهذا اسمها اما حقيقتها فمجرد
تحالف ميليشيات اغلبها كردي بدا معركه
الرق تعلن ذلك من بلده عين عيسى التي تبعد
50 كرا على الاقل عن الرقه وتترك الامر
لاحدى ناشطات لتكريس صوره يراد لها ان
تشيع عنهم فاذا هم في الصوره مقاتلون
ومقاتلات من اجل الحريه قد تكون الحقيقه
غير ذلك بالنسبه للبعض فهؤلاء مليشيات
انشئ على عجل للقيام بدور وظيفي ليس اكثر
لا يزيد عددهم عن ال الفا دربتهم وتدربهم
الولايات المتحده ويحظون بدعمها العسكري
وهاهم يعلنون قبل غيرهم
بدء معركه الرقه ولا باس ان يقوم الراعي
الرسمي بتصحيح جزء من الصوره فهؤلاء اي
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه جزء من المرحله
الاولى لعمليه الرقه وهي العزل والتطويق
قبل الاقتحام اما من يفترض ان يدخل
المدينه فعرب بالضروره وفقا لمبعوث الرئيس
الامريكي لمكافحه الارهاب لماذا يقول
الرجل هذا لان الرق في سوريا وكذلك الموصل
في العراق مدينتان كبيرتان تقعان على خط
النار في الحرب لدحر تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه انهما اكبر معقل للتنظيم والاهم
اثنيا وطائفيا انهما تتكونان من غالبيه
سنيه ساحقه وتتعرض كما يؤكد البعض لمحاوله
تغيير ديموغرافي من شانه الاخلال بالتوازن
الهش في سوريا والعراق معا في الموصل ثمه
الحشد الشعبي يقاتل الى جوار القوات
الحكوميه وكلاهما يحظى بدعم جوي من قوات
التحالف هناك كما يقول البعض خطط لتغليب
طائفه على اخرى اي للقيام بعمليات تهجير
منهجيه على اسس مذهبيه وتحويل سنه المدينه
الى اقليه اذا امكن في الرقه على الطرف
الاخر ثمه ميليشيات كرديه تحارب ايضا تحت
غطاء التحالف الدولي اي انها وفقا للبعض
الحشد الشعبي في نسخته الكرديه وهم لا
يخفون طموحاتهم التاريخيه لانتزاع شريط
طويل وممتد على حدود البلدين لاقامه كيان
سياسي قد تتيحه لهم التغييرات العاصفه في
المنطقه في الرقه الغالبيه سنيه كما في
الموصل العراقيه ووحدها تركيا من يحذر
بالنسبه لانقره هناك ما تعتبره خطوطا
حمراء على الجبهتين وتتمحور حول تغييب
العنصر العربي والسني تحديدا ما يؤثر على
امنها الداخلي امر يفسر تحذير نائب رئيس
الوزراء التركي من ان استخدام عناصر غير
عربيه لطرد مسلحي تنظيم الدوله لن يسهم في
احلال السلام في
اضافه الى هذا يعرف المسؤولون الاتراك ان
اطلاق قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه اسم غضب
الفرات على عمليتهم في الرقه قد يكون ردا
عليهم او تحديا لهم لا تحسم المعارك
بالرموز فحسب بل بالتحالفات والقوه على
الارض هذا ما تعرفه انقره فمن يدعم اكراد
سوريا ياتي اليهم في نهايه المطاف لينس
وربما ليكي خططه بما لا يضر انقره على
الاقل
نرحب بضيوفنا في هذه الحلقه من اسطنبول
رسول توسون عضو حزب العداله والتنميه
التركي من باريس كدار بيري مدير مؤسسه كرد
بلا حدود ومن واشنطن اندرو تابلر كبير
الباحثين في معهد واشنطن لسياسات الشرق
الادنى نبدا بالسيد اندرو تابلر في في
واشنطن ما هو الموقف الحقيقي الرسمي
الامريكي من اعلان سوريا الديمقراطيه بد
عمليه استعاده
الرقه الموقف
الامريكي بالرغم من انه كان هادئا هي انها
تدعم قوات الديمقراطيه السوريه وجهودها ل
محاص رقه والاستيلاء
عليها و
هذا هي مرحله اولى للضغط على
رقه وهناك
استعدادات منذ
مده ولكن المرحله الثالثه من هذه العمليه
الاستيلاء على
المدينه هي ما تزال في المستقبل وستكون
تحت اشراف الرئيس الامريكي الجديد ولكن
سيد تابلر الاكراد حلفاء وانقره حليفه هل
هذا يحرج واشنطن في تعاملها مع هذا
الملف نعم انه يفعل ذلك لان
تركيا
اعلنت انها تريد ان يكون هناك منطقه
امنه بين في سوريا لكنها لا تريد من
الاكراد ان
يتواصلوا مع راجو فا وفرين
كانتون
وتركيا والقوات
التركيه تريد ان تستولي على رقه وهذا يعني
ان الولايات المتحده لها حليفان واحد من
النيتو حلف شمال الاطلسي والاخر هو حليف
بمستوى اقل جديد ويحارب من اجل نفس الهدف
وذلك سيؤدي الى عدم الاستقرار
وقد يؤجل التغلب على تنظيم الدوله ولكن هل
يشعر الاكراد سيد كدار بيري في باريس هل
يشعر الاكراد
بانهم
مسنود في هذه العمليه التي سيشرعون فيها
قريبا تحيه لك ولضيوفك ولمشاهده دعني اوضح
فقط اصحح تقريركم الذي وردت اموه باسم
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه كميلي شيا وهذا
الامر مرفوض بينما تذكرون اسم تنظيم داعش
الارهابي بالدوله الاسلاميه هذا هذا الامر
بدايه مرفوض كرديا وعالميا اما بمساله
مساله التخوف التركي ارجو ان لا يكون هناك
تخوفات تركيه ولماذا تخاف تركيا اذا كانت
القوات التي ستشارك في هذه المعركه هي
ثوار الرقه لواء احرار الرقه لواء شهداء
الرقا لواء شهداء حمام التركمان المجلس
العسكري السورياني كلهم سيشاركون ما سيدخل
مدينه الر اسمح لي فقط سيد بيري اسمح لي
فقط اسمح لي فقط يعني قبل الخوض في
المخاوف التركيه انا اسال ان كان الاكراد
يشعرون بانهم مدعومون من امريكا في هذه
العمليه موضوع السيطره على الرقه من بكل
تاكيد بكل تاكيد البارحه البارحه فقط وصلت
اخر التعزيزات والدعم العسكري الامريكي
الى مدينه كوبان كي تستمر المعركه
والتجهيزات اصبحت كامله عسكريا ونفسيا
وميدانيا ولكن هناك نقاط ارجو ان لا
تقاطعني بشكل دائم لانني هناك نقاط علي ان
اوضحها كي اوصل الصوره بشكل صحيح الى
المشاهد هذا هو واجبي تفضل لا انا قطعتك
مره واحده مش بشكل دائم مره واحده فقط
اريد ان اسال ضيفنا التركي سيد رسول طوسون
واضح ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تقف مع قوات سوريا ديمقراطيه في
هذه العمليه وهذا اثار امتعاض تركي لماذا
تنزعج انقره من من مثل هذا
الدعم مواقف الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
مواقف خاطئه اطلاقا لماذا لان المبرر
الاساسي لتواجد الولايات المتحده في
المنطقه هو مكافحه الارهاب لكننا ن رى ان
الامريكيين يكافحون تنظيما ارهابيا بتحالف
مع تنظيم ارهابي
اخر هناك قوات سوريه الديمقراطيه اسمها
لكن اغلبيه هذه القوات تتشكل من وحدات
حمايه الشعب هذه الوحدات امتداد لتنظيم
فكك الارهابي الذي يعترف به الغرب وكذلك
الولايات المتحده انه ارهابي معنى هذا ان
وحدات الشعب الكرديه هذا تنظيم
ارهابي اذا في في هذه الحاله سيد توسون
اذا في هذه الحاله لماذا اذا في هذه
الحاله سيد توسون بعد اذنك في هذه الحاله
في هذه الحاله لماذا تتجاهل واشنطن هذا
الراي لانقره وتتعامل مع هذا التنظيم بكل
اريحيه على ما
يبدو
هناك مشاكل كبيره في الحقيقه بين انكره
وواشنطن
ف بغض النظر عن ما قاله وزير الخارجيه
التركيه قبل فتره ان بيننا وبين امريكا
اشكاليه ومشكله ومشاكل كبيره الشارع
التركي فقد الولايات المتحده فقدت
مصداقيته في الشارع التركي لكن تركيا
تحاول ان ترمم العلاقات وتحاول ان تقنع
الولايات المتحده وان تحذر حتى تعود من
هذا الخطا البارز لان هناك تنظيم ارهابي
فاذا فتحوا او اذا حرروا مدينه الرقه من
تنظيم ارهابي يسلمون الى تنظيم ارهابي
اخر بالنسبه لموقف الامريكيون بالنسبه
بالنسبه بالنسبه للموقف الامريكي اسمح لي
اسمح لي فقط سيد سون بالنسبه للموقف
الامريكي هناك مساله نريد ان نسال عنها
السيد اندرو تابلر الولايات المتحده لماذا
لا تنسق مع كل حلفائها سواء تركيا او قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه حتى تتجنب حدوث حساسيات
من هذا القبيل الذي التي عبر عنها الان
ضيفنا من
اسطنبول مع حلفاء والحلفاء لا يتفقون مع
الولايات المتحده هذا
ليس هذا ليس
جديدا
و حليفه مجك
وال القوات او السلطات
التركيه الان لدينا
تفاهم حول هذا الامر
واود للمشاهدين ان يفهموا او
يتذكروا ان احد افضل الامور بالنسبه
لولايات المتحده ان لدينا انتخابات كل
اربع
سنوات وسوف نعرف غدا نامل ذلك من يفوز
بهذه الانتخابات وان ذلك الرئيس الجديد
سوف ياخذ البلد الى
اتجاه طبعا الولايات المتحده تعزز
علاقاتها بحلفائها في المنطقه احد الحلفاء
هو تركيا ومن المهم ان نضع ذلك بعين
الاعتبار وامل ان جميع الاطراف في الشرق
الاوسط سواء كانت تركيا او
قواه تتذكر ذلك
نعم بعد الفاصل سنناقش خيارات تركيا وقوى
المعارضه السوريه المتحالفه معها لمواجهه
تمدد وحدات الحمايه الكرديه الى الرقه لنا
عوده
[موسيقى]
ت
المتحدث العسكري باسم قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه السيد كدار بيري هذا المتحدث
قال اتفقنا مع التحالف الدولي على استبعاد
اي دور لتركيا والفصائل المتحالفه معها في
معركه الرقه على اي اساس بنى هذا التاكيد
الجازم
هو بنى تاكيده بكل تاكيد على التحركات
والتصرفات التركيه طيله خمس سنوات من
المعمعه داخل سوريا ب بنى تصريحه على
الدعم التركي المباشر لتنظيم داعش والذي
لا يخفى هذا الامر على احد ب بنى اقتراحه
هذا على دخول مدينه جرابلس بالطريقه
التركيه التي لم يكن هناك طلقه واحده
باتجاه داعش داعش التي غيرت ملابسها فقط
في تركيا ورفع العلم التركي وايضا في
مكاتبهم من ي يعون بانهم الجيش الحر وهم
ليسوا كذلك جيش الحر بريء منهم فهم من
ادعوا يدعون صور اردوغان وصور اتاتورك في
في مكاتب في مكاتبهم بينما التحرير على
طريقه قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه ستكون كما
في مدينه منبج بتر داعش من المنطقه بشكل
كلي ولهذا ار الطرف الامريكي ان يتحالف مع
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه وليس مع الطرف
التركي نعم ذكروا اساس الامريكيين والقاده
العسكريين ايضا بان تركيا ستكون لها لاحقا
دور نعم سيكون لها لها دور ودور مميز جدا
وتكون مشكوره عليه ان قامت فقط باغلاق
الحدود من طرفها امام في وجه الارهابيين
التي هي تقوم بادخالهم ان قامت بهذا الدور
فهذا سيكون انجاز كبير تقدمه للشعب السوري
عامه ول حمله الرقه بشكل خاص ف اكتفت بهذا
فهذا امر اكثر من جيد واكثر من رائع ستكون
مشكوره عليه اما ما قام به
سيد باستبعاد اي طرف اخر لان العالم ادرك
جميعا بان قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
وتجربتها في محاربه داعش هي الانجح
والافضل للقضاء على هذا التنظيم الارهابي
نعم ولكن ولكن الدور التركي يبدو منظور
اليه من زاويه اخرى هنا نسال سيد رسول
توسون اشتون كارتر وزير الدفاع الامريكي
قال لقاءاتنا مستمره مع الاتراك لنبحث
معهم الدور المحتمل الدور المحتمل لتركيا
في موضوع الرق
ما هذا الدور الذي يمكن ان تلعبه
تركيا بدايه اريد ان افتح
قوس تركيا اول دوله اعلنت ان داعش تنظيم
ارهابي ونشرت في جريدت الرسميه بانها
تنظيم ارهابي وكافحت تركيا كل التنظيمات
الارهابيه بما فيها داعش والان تكافح من
خلال درع الفرات لتنظف الاراضي الس سيه من
داعش فلماذا تفضل
امريكا قسد او قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
الذي يشكل عموده الفقري تنظيم ارهابي بيدا
لان هذه القوى امريكا تراها قريبه منها
لان المعارضه السوريه اغلبيتها اسلاميين
وهذه هذا التحالف قصد تحالف علماني لذلك
الولايات المتحده برؤيه صليبيه تفضل هؤلاء
على المعارضه وعلى تركيا ايضا تركيا كما
قلت تركيا دوله كبيره لها
اتفاقيات برؤيه صليبيه سيدان برؤيه صليبيه
نعم نعم نعم نعم نعم نعم برؤيه
صليبيه بالذات يعني اخترت هذه الكلمه
بالذات لان المواقف الامريكيه للاسف وكذلك
المواقف غربيه في القضايا الشرق الاوسيه
والاسلاميه تنبق من خوفهم من الاسلام
وكذلك من الدواعي او من النزاعات اليبيه
اما
بالنسبه حول هذه النقطه تح لنسال السيد
لنسال السيد اندرو بعد اذنك لنسال السيد
اندرو تابلر ان كان لديه تعليق حول هذه
المساله لانه يبدو ان الغضب التركي من
الموقف الامريكي وصل الى هذه الدرجه التي
نسمعها الان من ضيفنا
انا لست متاكدا ما هو
السؤال المعارضه
السوريه تشمل او تضم
اسلاميين وبعض تلك
المجموعات المعتدله كما يطلق عليها تدعمها
القوات الولايات المتحده
اما السلفيون او الجاهلون فان الولايات
المتحده لا تدعمهم وهذا معروف وهذه
سياسه ثابته
وستظل تستمر في المستقبل هناك مصادر قلق
بان الاكراد قد يكون من الاقليات في
سوريا لديهم طابع
اسلامي
لكن من الناحيه اخرى فان سوريا بلد
اغلبيته مسلمه وهو في وضع حرب وهذه
المجموعات التي تقاتل
النظام اصبح لها شعبيه والرئيس الامريكي
الجديد سوف يقرر ان كان سيقوم بدور اكبر
في سوريا في ارساء الاستقرار او ان يبعدهم
او يبعد تلك المجموعات عن الجهاديين
والسلفيين وللقيام بذلك ينبغي ان تذهب
وتتحدث الى بلدان مثل تركيا ويمكن ان
تتحدث الى القوات الديمقراطيه السوريه
ولكن تتحدث الى البلدان المجاوره والى
الحلفاء الامر صعب خاصه اذا اردت ان تاخذ
هو ايضا هو ايضا صعب هو ايضا صعب على على
الاتراك لنسال في نهايه البرنامج سيد رسول
توسون ما الذي يمكن باختصار رجان ما الذي
يمكن ان تقوم به تركيا اذا خذلتها امريكا
مره اخرى وحاولت بعد ذلك ان تجبر بخاطرها
قليلا مثل ما فعلت في
الموصل الولايات المتحده في الحقيقه بين
حين واخر تتخذ مواقف متعارضه
ومتناقض مع حلفائها ومع الاتفاقيات
المبرمه فيما بينها لكن بعد ذلك بعد فتره
نرى انهم ياتون ويعتذرون ثم ايضا هم
يحاولون ترميم هذه الاخطاء المشكله الكبرى
الان لدى الولايات المتحده هي ان الرئيس
الحالي هو الارجل الاعرج في يعني نحتاج
نحن نتائج الانتخابات الامريكيه ونرى
الموقف الجديد للرئيس الجديد بعد ذلك
اعتقد سيتبلور
الموقف الامريكي من القضيه السوريه وكذلك
من القضيه العراقيه وتركيا تتخذ قراراتها
بعد هذه المواقف المتوقعه شكرا جزيلا لك
رسول توسون عضو حزب العداله والتنميه
التركي من اسطنبول شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من
باريس كدار بيري مدير مؤسسه كرد بلا حدود
وللضيف من واشنطن اندرو تابلر كبير
الباحثين في معهد واشنطن لسياسات الشرق
الادنى بامان
الله